♪♪♪♪
-Hello, everybody, and welcome
back to "Corrections"
for the week of Monday, May 3rd.
For those of you
who are joining "Corrections
for the first time,
this is our effort,
with the help of our viewers
to make right
everything that we got wrong
over the course of the week.
Because I think all great ar
is at its best
when it is crowdsourced.
[ Laughter ]
I said "LCD display" when I wa
referring to a television.
It was pointed out to me tha
the "D" in LCD is "display."
So I basically said "liqui
crystal display display."
That was obviously an error,
and I meant to say
"LC display."
"Tumeric" is how I have though
it was my whole life.
It's "turmeric."
Sal wrote it "turmeric," and I
literally looked at it and said,
"You're a dope."
Took the "R" out.
Spell check told me I was wrong.
Said, "You're a dope."
[ Laughter ]
Confidently went out here
and said "tumeric,"
and then correctly was tol
it's "turmeric."
Which is a very unsettling wor
to say and hear.
Turmeric.
So, from now on,
we'll be using cumin.
[ Laughter ]
Some people --
This is -- You probably --
There was a little title car
in the beginning
that referred to this
as a digital exclusive.
A lot of people have pointed out
all television now is digital,
and so it's not really
a big deal to say it's digital
I'd like to also point out -
it ain't that exclusive.
[ Laughter ]
Did any of you watching this
get a special invite?
Two-party verification
on your way in?
So, I think
we're gonna just, uh...
I don't know, we'll make
a new title card.
"A big ol' sack of [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
I admitted that I say
"substantive" wrong.
I have been saying
"sub-STAN-tive."
Lot of British people
and Australian people
having my back on this.
That's the problem.
It's that I'm the only one her
who speaks the Queen's.
[ Laughter ]
And I'm surrounded by wankers!
Ugh.
I also said I was mad
that Sal could not find,
you know, an alternative
for "substantive."
And I said, "I guess they don'
have any thesauruses
at his home."
The plural of thesaurus
is thesauri.
Thesauruses
were a kind of dinosaur...
[ Laughter ]
...that was -- it was big --
they were big, large.
Massive, huge.
Gigantic, colossal.
I should also note,
we're trying very hard
to get "Corrections"
a little shorter.
So, that will be the effort,
is to bring the time down
on "Corrections."
Because last week
when it was over,
Shoemaker pointed out to m
that it was a little long.
I mean, he didn't say it
like that.
He was like --
[goofy accent] "Ayyyy!
Whaddya doin'-a my time?!
I gotta get out the door!
Mikey the Shoe's got
meetings to make!"
[ Laughter ]
"You don't make --
You don't keep it
under 10 minutes,
you're gonna get the one
and then the two!"
You think I'm 'fraid-a you
Aaaaah, Mikey the Shoe
ain't afraid-a nobody!
I wasn't afraid of Son of Sam!
[ Laughter ]
"Ehhh, summer of '76!
Everybody was lockin'
their doors.
Not Mikey the Shoe!
He was out in the streets sayin'
'Come and get me, Sammy!'"
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice] I said that
Kroger bought Piggly Wiggly.
It turns out,
Kroger bought Pick 'n Save
But then I explained my decision
by saying
I only refer to companies
by their parent company.
But then a lot of people
pointed out I said Ben & Jerry
when I should have said
Unilever.
I mentioned Ben & Jerry.
It was lighthearted.
I was basically pointing out
that some talk show hosts
have received, over the years,
their own Ben & Jerry's flavor
Whatever.
Good for them.
No, I'm genuinely --
It's a great company,
and I'm happy for my colleagues.
And, uh...
they're not the only ice cream
company in the world.
So keep an eye out
for Late Night
with Seth Breyers.
[ Laughter ]
Someone for real said,
"You know what a good --
You know what a good
Ben & Jerry's flavor
would be for you?
Amber Says Nuts."
[ Laughter ]
-No!
-We've talked a lot about
whether an Irish gnome,
troll, or elf
would need a visa
if they went to Iceland.
I've received
maybe the most information
correcting me on this.
My biggest takeaway now is tha
because both of those countrie
are in the EEA, which is
the European Economic Area
there would not be the nee
for any visa.
But after three months,
they would have to apply
for residency
in order to pay taxes
on their earnings.
However, thanks to Brexit,
if you were a Northern Irish
gnome, troll, elf, or fairy...
it -- it's a lot harder
for you now.
So, thanks for nothing, Brexit
I -- I'm embarrassed
that I did this,
but I guess
I didn't say "library,"
I said "libarry."
I think it's maybe
'cause I had a cold,
I just double clutched on it
'Cause I know it's "library.
And not "libarry."
"Libarry" is what Biden says
when Obama tells him
he can't make dinner
because he has other plans
"That's a damn lie, Barry!
[ Laughter ]
Prince Charming.
I referred in "A Closer Look
last night --
we were talking about Snow White
getting cancelled, and, uh..
It shouldn't -- I mean,
Snow White's getting cancelled
If anything, Prince Charming's
getting cancelled.
You know, he's the one
who kissed a sleeping woman.
Who --
assumed dead.
Everyone -- You know,
people are like,
"Kissed her without consent.
It's like, uh,
way worse than that.
[ Laughter ]
Full-on came up on a dead woma
in a glass case...
gave her a kiss.
And then she woke up.
And he was like, "Great."
[ Laughter ]
'Cause I feel like
a more likely out--
[ Laughing ]
I feel like there's
a kind of guy who's like,
"I'm gonna go give
that dead body a kiss,"
who if it woke up would be like,
"No, no, no, no, no!"
"Aah!"
Prince Charming --
I said that they're all --
Prince Charming were
all of those Disney princes.
It was pointed out to me
that's not the case.
Sleeping Beauty
was Prince Phillip,
who then went on
to marry the queen.
[ Laughs ]
Um...
Last one.
So, "sommelier."
We were talking about that
and how I said it wrong,
and I still don't even kno
if I'm saying it right,
but I said it was
particularly hard
for me to realize
I didn't know how to say i
because my mom was
a middle school French teacher
She was my middle school
French teacher,
she was my brother's
middle school French teacher
And I also said that every night
before dinner,
and one of the reasons I shoul
know how to say "sommelier,"
is she would make, um...
she would make my brother and
drink a full bottle of wine.
And I had never
told anybody that.
And, uh...
It felt good to say it.
And it felt good to say it
to the group of people
who I feel like I'm going
through these corrections with
because we're just trying
to make each other better.
And admitting it to you
was a relief to me.
And then, um...
after I said that my mothe
made my brother and I
drink a full bottle of win
every night,
no less than 500 of you said
"My brother and me."
[ Laughter ]
[Bleep] ass[bleep]
Mikey the Shoe,
how we doing on time?
-Oh, it's really long.
-[ Laughs ]
Well, I better go, then,
'cause I'm a-gonna get it.